la segunda alfombra roja de este
festival de cannes también fue para uno
francés recordemos que de las 24
películas en competencia 7 son francesas
y en eso tiene que ver también la crisis
del cómic 19 esta noche que en camino
por la alfombra roja entonces fue ganzúa
o son que presentó su película todo
ocurrió bien una película basada en
hechos reales que habla de un tema
complicado como es el fin de vida y la
eutanasia protagonizada por la actriz su
fin marzo que pese a los años que lleva
en el cine es primera vez que participa
de la competencia en el festival de
cannes en otra de las secciones para
leerlas la quincena de realizadores
también fue un francés el que se estrenó
esta noche aunque él es un escritor pero
también director de cine manuel carrera
que estrenó ouistreham o una película
basada en un libro no suyo sino de la
periodista logos o pena que habla de la
precariedad esta periodista se infiltró
en un grupo de empleadas domésticas y de
eso habla justamente esta película